when I signed with Capital Records they
they paid me 500 for the master of of My
Bologna three or four years later when I
re-recorded it for my first real album I
think they charged me a thousand dollars
for the right to re-record it and that
my friends was why they call it the
record business
hello I'm Weird Al Yankovic and these
are my iconic tracks
[Music]
I recorded it in the bathroom across the
hall from my college campus radio
station kcpr 91.3 San Luis Obispo I just
sent in that that bathroom recording to
Dr Demento and he played it on the radio
I couldn't believe it because it was
number one on the funny five for like
two three weeks in a row I went to a a
knack concert I don't know how he did
but I snuck backstage somehow uh after
the show and I met Doug Fieger the lead
singer of The Knack and I introduced
myself and he was like oh here's a My
Bologna guy and oddly enough the guy who
was right was the Vice President of
Capitol Records who just happened to be
at that show I was in school getting my
degree in architecture I wasn't
passionate about that I didn't really
want to be an architect uh but I didn't
really think I could make a living in
Showbiz that was just such an alien
concept to me but the fact that I now
had a single on Capitol Records like the
home of the Beatles you know the big
tower in Hollywood like that was a huge
deal and it got me thinking
well maybe I can do this
remember when I recorded it in the
studio I was so nervous when we recorded
it way too fast I didn't have a record
deal at the time it was kind of done on
spec and it's expensive to be in the
studio and I was doing the math and uh
like oh if I take a bathroom break it's
going to cost me 20 bucks you know I'm
still working in a minimum wage job at
the time and at that you know I was very
aware of like you know money flying out
the window and My Bologna I think I knew
when we recorded it oh this is way too
fast but it's fine move on next song
next song
efficiency and white and nerdy look at
me I don't think it was like spontaneous
inspiration I think I probably sat with
a Chamillionaire track because I was a
huge hit and I was like what can I do
with this and then I thought oh White
and Nerdy
that's my life that's my whole existence
I don't need to research this song I
spent my whole life doing research on
this song so uh the ideas came pretty
quickly and I had dozens of pages of
notes because I wanted to write down
every single nerdy thing that I'd ever
done or thought about doing in my life
and put it all in one song key and peel
at this point I believe are probably
most famous for being on Mad TV I think
I knew key or we had some some mutual
friends uh and I thought oh these guys
would be great I love these guys to this
day people are discovering the key and
peeler in the video like oh I just
watched the white nerdy key and peeler
in the video
it blows their minds
[Music]
I started playing the accordion October
22nd 1966 and I took lessons for three
years that's my formal musical training
they only teach you polkas and classical
pieces and you know when I was getting
in my pre-teen years I just was more
interested in the songs I was hearing on
the radio I thought it would be fun to
do a parody of Another One Bites the
Dust because it's got a such a
distinctive Baseline it's a very simple
song it's very powerful but simple and
simple is good when you're trying to
emulate it on an accordion that was
maybe what 20 years old maybe 21 and uh
I was debuting my new song Another One
Rides the Bus and I I needed somebody to
to bang on my recording case and this
guy John said oh well I'm a drummer and
I said
bang away and uh as it turns out he's
now been banging away he's been my
drummer for 42 years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I had high hopes for eat it but I had no
conception of how big it would be it was
overnight Fame you know it that which
seems like a myth but literally the day
after eat it went into heavy rotation on
MTV I was recognized everywhere I went
because and back then you know people
were obsessed with MTV this is like
1984. people were so intimately familiar
with the Michael Jackson video that it
was very easy to do a parody because all
we had to do was recreate it but just
tweak things just a little bit we did
have the same uh uh choreographer Vince
Patterson who was the gang leader in the
Michael Jackson video happily he agreed
to be in my video as well I tried as
hard as I could to dance like Michael
Jackson and that's why it's funny
because I am not a dancer I've never
been a dancer I'm just this
uncoordinated lanky Weirdo And and the
fact that this guy is trying to dance
like Michael Jackson you know that
that's funny because it's it's not
happening
[Music]
Amish products was one of my first
hip-hop slash rap songs people you know
are curious about what the Amish
actually thought of the video and I
found out the Amish as a rule aren't big
MTV Watchers yeah I haven't gotten a lot
of Amish feedback I did in my own stunt
in that one I could have died
because the the Buster Keaton gag of the
falling Barn the falling house there's a
barn frame that falls
on top of me and that's all real that's
not a camera effect or anything like
that they wanted to make sure that the
barn frame wouldn't torque or move so
what they did was they reinforced it
with steel so this thing weighed a ton
probably literally they said you have to
stand right here in this little square
don't move because if you move literally
you will die so we did one take of that
and I did some of my best acting I've
done in my life I had to pretend like I
wasn't scared out of my mind the Coolio
thing has been talked about to death you
know he had a problem with it initially
because there were some crossed wires he
did not approve it apparently initially
and we we were told that he did because
his producer had approved it and there's
miscommunication there that all got
straightened out I mean you know within
a few years you know we hugged it out
and we made up and uh I'm glad that
there wasn't any kind of you know bad
blood or ill will we were you know we're
fine
[Music]
I love Rocky Road was my second music
video and these were non-union days uh
one day shoot meant like 22 hours
in a row like you got one day to shoot
this like okay this day will never end
we're gonna keep shooting till we're
done
musical mic was in the video the guy
that does the the hand music we featured
him a lot in the early material and
there were stuff that we never got
around to shooting because uh I guess
the day wasn't planned out that well we
actually had a dozen kids from an
accordion school with their accordions
we never got around to shooting it got
to be like two o'clock in the morning
like okay kids you can go home now I
hear those ice cream bells and I start
to drool
an old Hollywood trick is when you're
shooting ice cream on screen you don't
use ice cream because it melts very
quickly there's no continuity so we use
mashed potatoes so anytime you see me in
that video holding an ice cream cone
it's mashed potatoes but there's one
shot where I was supposed to take a bite
to the ice cream cone so it's like two
scoops of latex paint covered mashed
potatoes and one scoop of real Rocky
Road ice cream I turned my head quickly
and during my head turn the actual scoop
falls off so I take a huge bite of latex
covered mashed potatoes I think we got
through the shot but it was disgusting
screaming and I don't know what I'm
singing smells like Nirvana I I think
was uh the closest we've ever gotten to
using the original everything because we
shot that on the same Sound Stage that
Nirvana shot their video on uh we had
most if not all of the same cheerleaders
we had the same janitor guy so it felt
very real you know and and we I think we
had a kind of convince people that we
weren't like mocking Nirvana or making
fun of them you know they understood
pretty early on we were being very
respectful we didn't have a celebrity
Cameo people were kind of flaking out on
us and I forget who but somebody in the
crew said oh I know Dick Van Patten I
said
Ben Patton so he called him up and
within like an hour he was on the set
and he was doing that crazy thing where
he's like in the audience with all these
like hardcore you know Nirvana fans
I did not even know that Tony Hawk was
in the video until like he tweeted it
like two decades later he said something
like oh this reminds me of one who's on
the Weird Al video for smells like
Nirvana and I was like you were in the
video so I I can kind of see him you can
freeze frame it and kind of pinpoint oh
yeah it's Tony Hawk that's him when I
write a parody I try to make everything
as funny as I possibly can and there's
nothing funny about a guitar solo so
it's like you think okay what would be
funnier than like you know a guitar solo
here like oh well you got your gargling
kazoo chorus they're very spiked
jones-isms like you know Spike Jones and
the City Slickers a very popular comedy
band in the 40s and 50s and early 60s
and one of my heroes I've borrowed a lot
of things from him like all the crazy
instruments and the sound effects and
things like that uh whenever possible I
try to have a little nod to spike
[Music]
I think to this day it might be my most
popular uh original song It's a Pastiche
or a Style parody where it's not a
direct parody but it's it's meant to
sound like an artist or or a group a lot
of my past issues aren't necessarily
based on how popular an artist is it's
based on my personal love of their body
of work and I'm a huge Devo fan and I
was like I want to write a song like
Devo would write and uh dare to be
stupid was the result of that for the
video we tried to use as many devo-isms
as we possibly could we've studied every
single video that Diva put out there's
the yellow radiation suits there's the
the scene with the uh the kind of
pantyhose pulled over their faces I made
a list of like you know a woman cutting
a kiwi you know just like random things
that we thought like oh that's something
Devo might do why not
foreign
wrote the song for the uh Running With
Scissors album I would like write pages
and pages of notes and here's an idea
and here's an idea and here's an idea
and I thought okay now I got to cut this
down to song Length and that's when I
thought no I'm not going to cut it down
I'm just going to do the whole thing
I really thought nobody's going to
listen to this more than once I made it
on purpose as long and as obnoxious as I
possibly could it was I was basically
trolling my fans saying like oh you want
you want a long song and uh it goes on
forever it wound up being one of my most
popular songs like fans like please play
Albuquerque like really so we've been
playing it live and uh it just boggles
my mind that people are love that song
[Music]
I'm back
the first time I saw the bad video I I
think it was the world premiere the
Michael Jackson Bad video I had the idea
for fat before the video was even over
you know usually I really think a long
time about my Concepts and think of all
the various options but no that I had
the idea immediately because I I just
envisioned like this 900 pound guy
trying to get through the turnstile in
the subway and I thought oh fact it's
got to be fat and it's it'll be like a
sequel to eat it it just makes so much
sense sense like I have to do this I
went back to Michael Jackson to make
sure he was okay with it and he was and
in fact and this was amazing he let us
use his set this time it was actually
Michael Jackson's set we were shooting
on and they were just about to strike it
they were just about to tear it down and
we found out we said no no let us shoot
there we did two days of shooting with
the dancers and everything and then the
third day we shot in the morning which
was only the face blowing up shot and
nowadays that would be like an easy CGI
thing you could just do that with
computers no big deal but this was 1988
so that was done practically so what
they did was they glued these like latex
bladders like balloons they glued it to
my face but then they had tubes running
from my face to the ground and there
were special effects people laying on
the ground blowing through these straws
essentially to expand my face and uh I
think the take that we used I said okay
last take just blow up my face until it
explodes so they just blew up my face
until like it exploded on my head and we
used everything up until the the frame
where it explodes
[Music]
hey I have had a polka medley on
virtually every album I think there may
be two that I somehow didn't put a polka
medley on the medleys allow me to poke
fun at a lot of songs all at once it's
easier for me in a way because I'm not
having to come up with funny lyrics I
mean the it's the arrangement that's
funny so I get to focus on the the music
part of it and to to you know to find
the humor through the instrumentation
that exercise is a muscle that I don't
really get to exercise that much with
with the straight parodies polka face I
think was the first actual music video
that we created for one of the Pokemon
leaves because prior to that I had these
kind of pirate videos where I would
literally take the original videos you
know of the original artists and speed
them up so they would match my singing
so he did and we couldn't release those
officially because I stole them but for
polka face we did an Anna Jam I found
like a dozen or so animators that I
really thought were amazing and I said
you do this song you do this song you do
this song I didn't even ask what they
were doing I just said have fun and then
we just cut it all together and that was
the video
[Music]
it's a personal policy of mine never to
let somebody else suggest a parody idea
I I have somebody going through my fan
mail and taking out all the song
suggestions so I just don't want
somebody else saying oh I gave that Al
that idea the one exception that I made
was Madonna because uh as Legend has it
and I told the story a thousand times
but Madonna was talking to a friend of
hers one day in New York City and just
offhandedly who said oh I wonder when
Weird Al's gonna do like a surgeon and
her friend knew my manager and word got
back to me and I thought
not a bad idea
the most memorable thing about that day
was uh the lion there was a lion in the
video because uh there was a lion in
Madonna's Like A Virgin video for no
apparent reason we had to have a lion in
the hospital just roaming the Halls it
was funny and random but I will say that
we lost a lot of our extras that day a
lot of the uh actors that were playing
random people in the hallways as soon as
the the lion was on set they said yeah I
don't think this is worth my 50 a day I
think I'm going home now but it was a
fun video to do you know I I ride around
a lot on the floor as a hobby just it's
a personal thing that I like to do and
it was nice to be able to use that in a
music video
hardware store is a completely original
song it's not a Pastiche or anything
although I in all honesty it started out
as asset Pastiche I won't tell you of
which band because then it's going to
wind up as a Wikipedia entry but it kind
of went in a different direction as it
was being written and being recorded and
we decided oh no this is just like a an
actual Weird Al original I wanted to
write a song that was like impossibly
fast you know like impossible to do live
because again that became one of my most
popular songs and people like what are
you gonna play hardware store live it's
like it's hard to do that live it's hard
to that bridge in four-part harmony
it would be hard enough for me to do it
but for the rest of the band to like
sing in perfect sync in forward Harmony
probably not going to happen the number
27 has become sort of an in-joke with my
fans because I don't know how it started
really I guess I wrote a song or two
that had the number 27 and people you
know back in the day said like why the
number 27 and uh instead of answering
them I just kept using the number more
and more you know throughout my career
until it became like this in joke so
it's sort of like when you see the
number 27 it's just sort of like a
little secret handshake with the fans
I'm Weird Al Yankovic thanks for
watching and these were my iconic tracks